we just had a video on villain team ups
so i figured that a continuation to that
seems apt after all there's just
something very special about anime
villains
it's almost a trope now that a lot of
them can transform in various ways
others go from monstrosities into
handsome men and women while others just
do the opposite
some just go straight up into final
fantasy boss territory in terms of
appearances
however not all transformations are
created equal
some are more impactful than others so
for today i'll be going through what i
think are 10 of the most impactful and
memorable villain transformations in
anime alright
strap in tight we're in for one hell of
a ride
jojo has no shortage of transformations
that go from cool to downright bizarre
among them i think that the
transformation by the leader of the
pillar men is one of the coolest ones
it checks out when you think of it cars
is known as the ultimate life form and
his ability as the ultimate life form
allows him to take on the traits of any
life form just as he gets fired
by the nazis it's cars who comes out on
top by donning his stone mask
transforming into his most well-known
form the massacre at the follows is just
the icing on top the ultimate lifeform
has been unleashed
and this moment will forever be etched
into any jojo fan's memory as one of the
pivotal turning points in battle
tendency
now didn't you i mean what else did you
expect from a character whose entire
gimmick is some sort of transmutation
overhaul's entire shtick comes from his
ability to keep transforming things with
his quirk
and of course that includes himself and
boy what a scary set of transformations
he had as he battles our heroes
indeed that's the most fearsome part of
overhaul's powers
nothing is safe from his power of
reassembly not even your quirks you may
not have the reputation or the legacy
that someone like all for one had
but you'd be afool to underestimate a
super villain with this kind of
versatility it all culminates in his
ultimate transformation into his red
kaiju form
he meets his end at the hands of deku
but it sure took one hell of a chain of
battles for overhaul to be defeated
gave us some of the best animation we've
seen in the season two
how appropriate the right after overhaul
we have another character with a
suspiciously similar gimmick in jiggle
dike
[Applause]
yep two masters of transformation and
assimilation back to back while
transformation works a bit differently
in the god of high school universe
i think that jaguar dykes way of doing
it is quite neat i mean at the end of
the day
we're talking about a person who can
ascend into the realm of the gods
and he uses this angelic form to engage
gian mori in the last stretch of the
season he dons an appearance that would
put some jrpg bosses to shame with how
majestic and intimidating it is
it's not so much monstrous but there
really is a sense of wonder at the form
that he decides to take
then you get to see his powers in action
not for too long for a supposed season
final boss unfortunately the
transformation kind of fell flat because
of the ease in which jin mori destroys
him i mean with an appearance like that
i think he could put up a bit of a fight
do you think so
on the other hand rule of call is a
thing and i don't think that anyone else
in god of high school comes with a
second form
that looks as cool as the angelic form
that jekyll dyke had in the series
finale
one piece is 912th episode gave us one
hell of a transformation
we've known kaido to be a monster of a
villain and you know what makes him even
scarier
a scary transformation of course one
that resembles a very
very intimidating blue shenron just like
a good villain who prides himself on
power
kaido releases some blood curdling
screams while he transforms into his
dragon form he then proceeds to emerge
out of nowhere to shake fear in the
hearts of all those who oppose him the
transformation was cool enough but once
you add the entrance to the mix
whoa seriously with this powerful of an
entrance and that mighty of a form
how could anyone stand up to him i
really don't know how anyone could beat
this honestly speaking
coming up next is raggio from kill luck
hill for a show with such a major focus
on transformations and outlandish
outfits
it's a no-brainer that the ultimate
villain would be rocking such
transformations of her own we've got a
lot of memorable moments such as the
outfit swaps between the sisters and
ragio rocking junketsu however
i think that her peak transformation
moment comes when she puts on her
ultimate outfit shinra goketsu donning
an appearance that puts
every other life fiber transformation to
shame with how outlandish it looks
ragio terrorizes the heroes in this new
form the symbol of ragio's desire for
world domination doesn't disappoint as
it showcased some hilariously
overpowered abilities right after
easily defeating even our main heroines
and even after its defeat
ragio still manages to use it in his
space shuttle form to further her plans
the great thing about this
transformation is that it happens at the
end of an episode
providing one of the best cliffhangers
the series has given how kill nakil has
got a lot of great cliffhangers that's
saying something
i think that seeing shinra kogetsu is
probably one of the most hyped i've been
for an upcoming episode well while we're
on the topic of villains you know who
anime fans consider the true villains
region locks of course that's why we
have a great hero and the sponsor of
this video
expressvpn it's the premier vpn service
that will allow you to bypass those
pesky region locks and enjoy shows you
wouldn't normally be able to access
legally
i started using expressvpn and i never
looked back
i recently used it to watch some killer
kill fights just open expressvpn and
select the united states server and
boom now you can use it to watch
hundreds of different anime which aren't
available in your region and it does all
of this without slowing your internet
speeds down whatsoever
i can stream animate with blazing fast
speeds in hd quality
and never experience any buffering with
expressvpn you can also browse the
internet with the maximum security that
a vpn can provide
that includes hiding your location and
protecting you against the scourge of
attacks on privacy that are becoming
more and more prevalent as the days go
by and all you have to do is head on to
my description box and follow the
instructions to download expressvpn or
just go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube with expressvpn see a brand
new internet without limits
start your trial on the number one vpn
service now
[Music]
for all the lists that he topped on this
channel i think it's a breath of fresh
air seeing madhura at the midway point
of the list
no one wins forever even if you're one
of the most broken villains ever created
madonna may only be fifth on the list
but i think that his transformation is a
key event in the final arc being the one
moment
where i thought the good guys were
legitimately screwed
as if they weren't already well martha
is about to make it worse
after absorbing the power of the ten
tails madara goes on to unleash his six
paths transformation
gaining white hair and an edgy new
redesign no wonder he had to be written
out through some plot convenience
i'm glad i just mentioned shonen
villains that were so overpowered they
had to be defeated by plot convenience
because up next is aizen
aizen as a character is all about
transcending limits and achieving
godhood in a sense
this in turn is represented by his
constant evolution and transformation
some sort of natural selection logic if
you will the end of the fake garagura
town saw a minimum of three
aizen forms in the long battle and i
think that the best one among them is
the second one
the second one yes the one where he
emerged out of the shell thing with a
mullet and butterfly wings i think that
it ended up being his most memorable
form and it represented the perfect
turning point in the battle
that had largely been going in soul
society's favor until that moment
it's just the perfect form for a being
about to ascend into godhood a cross
between the image of a divine
being and a human technically speaking
his actual final form is way more
intimidating and is the stuff of
nightmares but that form just lacked the
charisma that this one had
not to mention it barely did anything
anyway we continue on with the shonen
train for our top three with the next
contender
broly
dragon ball has always been about
transformations it's the easiest way to
show a power-up after all and the show
is just rife with those
i can put sales forms on the list i
could put many boosts here
heck even frieza deserves a spot and
those are just the major villains
not even getting to the minor ones and
then of course there's broly i want to
give broly the spotlight here because i
feel his transformation carried a lot of
impact i mean the same can be said for
the other major villains i mentioned but
from a personal perspective i feel like
broly elicited the strongest reactions
from me
the first appearance of the old movie is
already something i mean he's brought
freaking vegeta to his knees in fear
while needing everyone's combined powers
to lose then there's the dragon ball
super transformation it's not too often
that you see a villain transformation
carry this much impact due to the voice
acting
this is a scene that still gives me
chills when i see how broly screams
as he completes this transformation you
can tell that the heroes are screwed
with how intense this moment is
and broly didn't disappoint two movies
two different eras
both badass and spine chilling
transformations broly truly knows how to
make an impact
i've talked about this moment a couple
of times before but i think that
griffith completing his fall into femto
is still one of the most powerful
moments in transformations in
anime griffith has been through a lot
and during the eclipse
he finally gives in to despair and gets
reborn as femto
femto then proceeds to do some
despicable acts that pretty much
encapsulates the mature themes that
berserk has been known for
the intervention of the skull knight
prevents things from getting even worse
for guts and kaska it's good that he
manages to arrive in time
as things were looking pretty bleak back
then despite the sad news about miura
i'm sure that berserk will live on with
his legacy and the number of works that
have been inspired by it
how it's managed to do that i would
personally say has a lot to do
with the beautiful art character writing
and gut-wrenching developments
some of them leading to chilling
transformations like this one
now i don't think this is a surprising
number one it's an easy decision to make
actually i know mentor or big brother
figure traitors are too rare in anime
but having those figures to be the most
iconic enemies that kick-started the
series
well looks like the greatest enemy is
within the ranks after all after
confiding with aaron
reiner and bertolt proceed to commit one
of the biggest betrayals and reveals in
modern anime
it's just an incredible and powerful
scene the music the cinematography
and the voice acting are all just so
perfect here this transformation is a
game changer in attack on titan and
that's why i place it as my number one
villain transformation
the two didn't disappoint either and the
ultimate battles against them ended up
being some of the most hyped fights
in the entire run of attack on titan
with that i end my list is there a
transformation that you think i missed
out on
write it down in the comment section so
i can check it out don't forget to check
out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
that wraps it up for this edition of
vinnie tube lists
i'm signing off and i hope to see you
next time
you